okay now let's get to the precondition
of the Donald Trump phone call with the
Ukrainian president on July 25th now I
want to explain this even more clearly
than I try to explain everything on the
show because this is so important we
have the whistleblower complaint which
has been released and it's related to
Donald Trump and Joe Biden and Ukraine
and the withholding of aid and
corruption and bribery and all of this
different stuff the focus has become did
Donald Trump offer a quid pro quo during
the July 25th phone call with the
Ukrainian president the quid pro quo
would be I am NOT going to give you 250
million or 400 million in military aid
unless and until you smear Joe Biden for
me okay and what the Trump
administration has done all week pretty
successfully is narrow the conversation
not about the suppression of
whistleblowers not about all of the
lead-up to this they've narrowed the
conversation to does this phone call
have irrefutable proof that Trump
threatened to withhold hundreds of
millions of dollars in exchange for
Ukraine smearing Joe Biden and
unfortunately it sort of worked because
the Trump administration ended up
putting out that bogus summary of the
call which is already incriminating but
it doesn't include an obvious quid pro
quo although it still seems to include
sort of an implicit one but Republicans
are now of course saying nothing to see
here see you looked at the phone call
even though it's a partial you know this
is just a segment of notes from the
phone call and there's no quid pro quo
in that one call now I've been telling
you for days this is not how things work
the phone call would not have been where
the quid pro quo was arranged the phone
call would have been the culmination of
something we now know about Rudy
Giuliani travelling all over the world
meeting with Ukrainian officials we now
know about all of these other elements
to this we know Trump is a mob involved
New York City real estate guy he knows
that you don't just get on a call with
no pre-negotiation and say hey Ukrainian
I'll give you the money if you smear Joe
Biden for me that's not how it works you
have your people set it all up in
advance so by the time you get on the
phone everything's already understood
and you can speak in generalities you
can speak in vague terms and there is
now a report from a former adviser to
the Ukrainian president who is saying
that phone call only happened because
smearing Biden had been established in
advance as a precondition of the call
and this is of course shocking but not
at all shocking this is how things work
this is how these things are done Sergei
Lysenko
I believe is the pronunciation was an
advisor to the Ukrainian president
during the transition period and he
explained that they were trying to get a
phone call between the incoming
Ukrainian president and Donald Trump and
quote it was clear that President Trump
will only have communications if we will
discuss the Biden case the issue was
raised many times I know that Ukrainian
officials understood and it genuinely
seems like the Ukrainian president was
not even remotely interested in getting
involved in the 2020 election and
helping Donald Trump to smear Joe Biden
the other shoes are dropping and they
are the exact style and size shoes that
we imagined were there and this tells us
that the whole premise of the phone call
the content of the phone call takes a
backseat when you understand that the
premise of the phone call was that there
had already been the precondition that
smearing Biden is going to be discussed
implied demanded whatever the case would
be Trump had no real interest in
speaking to the Ukrainian president
other than to talk about Joe Biden and
the investigation and the eventual smear
that he wanted to take place of Joe
Biden and then after the phone call
Trump administration officials had the
records of the call including a full
transcript and maybe a recording we
don't yet know moved to a different
computer system or server imagine being
the incoming Ukrainian president and you
have Putin on one side pressuring you
Trump on the other side to try to pull
you into helping him win reelection in
2020 it is a stunning an incredible
state of affairs that we find ourselves
in today we have an impeachment inquiry
we have the whistleblower complaint we
have news of the phone call having
already established as a precondition
that Joe Biden is going to be a topic it
is incredible that this is politics
today and you know the next 24 hours
could be even crazier than the last 24
and it's becoming actually difficult to
keep up after the break we will talk
about the latest from judge who says
Trump is absolutely impeachable for what
has gone on we will also talk about the
new polls two of which have Elizabeth
Warren leading nationally one of which
has Andrew yang at 8% do we believe any
of it that's coming up next